The beginning of everything.
The Big Bang is the idea that the universe was suddenly born and is not infinite
out to the middle of the 20th century.
Most scientists thought of the universe as infinite and ageless until Einstein's
theory of relativity gave us a better understanding of gravity and Edwin Hubble
discovered the galaxies are moving apart from one another in a way that fits
previous predictions.
In 1964 by accident,
cosmic background radiation was discovered,
a relic of the early universe,
which together with other observational evidence made the big bang.
The accepted theory in science since then improved technology like the Hubble
telescope has given us a pretty good picture of the Big Bang and the structure
of the cosmos.
Recent observations even seem to suggest that the expansion of the universe is
accelerating,
but how did this big bang work?
How can something come from nothing?
Let's explore what we know
we can ignore.
The beginning part for now,
first of all,
the big bang was not an explosion.
It was all space stretching everywhere all at once.
The universe started very,
very,
very small and quickly expanded to the size of a football.
The device didn't expand into it.
I think space was just expanding into itself.
The universe cannot expand into it.
I think because the university has no borders.
There is by definition no outside the universe.
The Universe is all there is and this hot,
dense environment energy manifested itself in particles that existed only for
the tiniest glimpses of time from blue ons,
powers of quarks or created which destroyed one another perhaps after giving off
more glue arms.
These found other short lift quarks to interact with forming new quark pass and
glue.
Once again,
matter and energy.
We're not just theoretically equivalent.
It was so hot.
They were practically the same stuff.
So where around this time matter,
one over anti matter.
Today we're left with almost all matter and nearly no anti matter at all.
Somehow 1,000,000,001 matter particles were formed for every 1 billion particles
of anti matter instead of one massive ultimate force in the universe.
They were now several refined versions of it acting under different rules.
By now.
The universe has stretched it to a billion kilometers in diameter,
which leads to a decrease in temperature.
The cycle of quarks being born and converted back to energy suddenly stops.
From now on.
We work with what we have.
Quarks begin forming.
New particles had Ron's like protons and neutrons.
There are many,
many combinations of quarks,
the conform,
all sorts of hydrogens,
but only very few are reasonably stable for any length of time.
Please take a moment to appreciate that.
Bye now.
Only one second has passed since the beginning of everything.
The universe which has grown to 100 billion kilometers is now cold enough to
allow most of the neutrons to decay into protons and formed the first atom
hydrogen.
Imagine that universe at this point has an extremely hot soup,
10 billion degrees Celsius filled with countless particles and energy.
Over the next few minutes,
things cooled and settled down very fast.
Atoms formed out of had Ron's and electrons making for a stable and electrically
neutral environment.
Some core this period,
the dark age because there were no stars and the hydrogen gas didn't allow
visible likes to move around,
but what's the meaning of visible light anyway when there's nothing alive yet
the could have eyes when the hydrogen gas clumped together after millions of
years and gravity put it under great pressure,
stars and galaxies began to form their radiation,
dissolve the stable hydrogen gas into a plasma that still permeates the universe
today and allows a visible light to pass.
Finally,
there was light.
Okay,
but what about the part we didn't talk about what happened right at the
beginning.
This part can be defined as the big bang.
We don't know at all what happened here.
At this point our tools break down natural law stop making sense.
Time itself becomes wibbly wobbly to understand what happened here.
We need a theory that unifies Einstein's relativity and quantum mechanics.
Something countless scientists are working on right now,
but this leaves us with lots of unanswered questions where their universe is
before our own.
Is this the first and the only universe?
What started the Big Bang or did it just occur naturally based on norms?
We don't understand yet.
We don't know and maybe we never will,
but what we do know is that the universe,
as we know it,
started here and gave birth to particles,
galaxies,
stars,
the earth,
and you,
since we ourselves are made of dead stars,
we are not separate from the universe.
We are part of it.
You could even say that we are the universe's way of experiencing itself.
So let's keep on experiencing as until there are no more questions to ask.